with reaction former secretary of state
mike pompeo
you know you said something really
caught my interest we'll start with
covet
that dr fauci saw everything you saw
but you came to a very different
conclusion than what he was saying
publicly
and what is it with them trying to
silence the state department
well sean thanks for having me on
tonight he certainly would have seen
everything that i saw there would have
been a whole bunch of folks that would
have seen
the same information he came to a
different conclusion or at least he
publicly stated that he did i don't know
how anybody could have seen
by march and april of 2020 how anyone
could have seen the accumulated evidence
surrounding the wuhan institute of
virology and conclude that there was no
chance that the
virus escaped from this place the
evidence had become overwhelming it
continues to grow
and yet i heard dr fauci this week say
oh i think the chinese have every
incentive
to come clean about this and that's
crazy naive sean
they have every incentive to do what
they did in 1989 which to kill thousands
of their
own people and today that's to cover up
what they did which has now resulted in
the deaths of
millions of people around the world i i
don't understand dr
fauci is continuing to tout and give the
chinese communist party a benefit of
doubt when they have no
no no not no sense earned that and then
i also don't understand why both
publicly and privately they were working
to make sure that the state department
my small team that was working on this
project
they didn't want us to complete the task
so
basically what you're saying would would
explain
why it was either april or may that
president trump then president trump
stated publicly that it likely came from
the lab which by the way we
everybody knew was involved in gain of
function research and involved with
coronaviruses
it kind of makes sense doesn't it
it does sean it look the evidence was
circumstantial but it was growing and
the evidence that this was a
transmission
issue was almost non-existent so the we
heard what president trump said what i
said in early may of 2020
we said that there was enormous evidence
that this was a an escape from this
virology laboratory that was being
operated in a dangerous way and sean
it's worth noting probably still is to
this day i haven't seen any
any indication they've changed what
they're doing there that this is a real
risk that is ongoing
we need to get to the bottom of it i
don't see any effort from the buy
administration to take seriously what
the chinese communist party
continues to be engaged in and put
impose enormous costs on them
so they'll stop doing this and stop
putting the american people at risk
you know we have big investment equity
firms goldman sachs deutsche bank
jp morgan chase they kind of know what
they're doing
i've yet to see any evidence that hunter
biden
had any experience in any of this
at all kind of like when he went on good
morning america and admitted
he had no experience in energy and oil
and gas
or ukraine and then the question was
well
why did they give you all this money
well i don't know he said
could it be that your father was vice
president probably
that was his answer now we have the
issue here
now 1.5 billion deal with the bank of
china
okay then we've got a hundred thousand
dollar shopping spree
from a chinese national now i don't know
mr secretary maybe i just believe in
following the law and i don't believe in
taking things for free
i don't think any chinese national would
ever give anybody watching this program
tonight
a hundred grand to take their family on
a shopping spree or a sweetheart deal
and bypass oh goldman sachs and deutsche
bank
and go with hunter biden then a crack
addict
and his new firm
sean the chinese communist party is very
strategic about how they spend every
penny i have never seen them give
one red cent when they didn't think they
were going to get an enormous return for
themselves
on their money so if they were providing
resources money to hunter biden
there was something they thought they
were getting it that there's no evidence
that that was
financial expertise or expertise in his
field
and when you when you hear the now
president then vice president biden say
well i never talked about my with my son
about those businesses at eames
it seems just as a dad that seems
incomprehensible to me
that that those topics didn't arise and
then the last point sean
remember uh back when he was vice
president he was traveling to ukraine
the state department officials george
kent the ambassador ivanovic
were very worried about his visit they
were worried about the story they were
going to tell and the connections
between
biden between hunter biden and burisma
that they might have to explain if vice
president biden took questions on his
visit there let me ask you if
if anyone with the last name trump or
hannity i don't know i always put myself
in this position
um if i got three and a half million
dollars from a russian oligarch the
former first lady of moscow and i got a
brand new expensive sports car from a
kazakhstan oligarch and then the whole
barista deal with no experience millions
of dollars and then the bank of china
joe biden denied ever talking to hunter
about any foreign business dealings now
we have pictures that have emerged of
him
not only talking about it meeting with
these foreign business partners of
hunter
my question to you is uh where's the
conflict of interest
uh investigation because if it was trump
i'm guessing there would be one
and we'd hear about it every second
every minute every hour of every day in
the media
shawn you would it'd be a top of the
fold washington post new york times
msnbc
every moment of every day there was
there was apparently a deep conflict of
interest here the
american people have a right to know
precisely what happened who got money
when and
why it's certainly the case that the
media wants to cover up
what vice president biden may have done
these conversations that he would have
had with his son
his involvement his connection when he
traveled to ukraine's vice president
these are important strategic questions
for american security you know mr
secretary
we need the adults back in charge that
actually get respect from these
countries because right now they're
testing biden
and i don't think he's meeting the
challenge at this moment
very challenging times thank you sir for
being with us
thank